herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
leute ich mache mal wieder was ganz
besonderes
medea tacos eines meiner lieblings
gerichte und nicht irgendwie sondern
nicht mehr dafür wieder richtig zeit um
genau zu sein 50 stunden
[Musik]
viele von den zutaten sind gar nicht so
leicht zu bekommen ich habe das glück
dass ich einen mexikanischen supermarkt
bei mir in der stadt habe und dort
konnte ich die verschiedenen teesorten
anschuss modezars kilo besorgen und
solche supermärkte zu erkunden macht mir
schon immer wahnsinnig viel spaß und die
möglichkeiten die sich dadurch eröffnen
sind einfach unglaublich
glaubt mir wenn man die kernel nicht
entfernt dann wird es richtig richtig
scharf
[Musik]
all das mit ein wenig grün und
anschließend wasser auffüllen
[Musik]
und aufkochen
aufräumen nicht vergessen
[Musik]
neben den chilis es die kräutermischung
verantwortlich für diesen unverkennbaren
geschmack und die stellen wir natürlich
selbst her
und fertig ist das ganze
[Musik]
wie getrockneter chilis geben durch das
aufkochen ihren gesamten geschmack ab
und werden quasi reaktiviert
[Musik]
ich glaube ich muss euch nicht sagen
dass die gerüche in der küche
unglaublich waren
[Musik]
jetzt stellen wir unsere bi ria marinade
her
[Musik]
wenn sich unsere marinade abgekühlt hat
und etwas gezogen ist kümmern wir uns um
das fleisch
[Musik]
ich habe bei der auswahl des
rindfleischs darauf geachtet dass es
einen hohen fettanteil hat weil wir all
dieses fett später benötigen werden
[Musik]
das muss ich dazu irgendetwas sagen
all das fest dass ihr hier seht noch das
fleisch schon beim braten abgegeben
[Musik]
jetzt wird es zeit für die hochzeit
nachdem wir unser fleisch gesalzen haben
gehen wir unsere marinade dazu
was soll ich da noch sagen
wenn alles bedeckt ist können wir den
deckel drauf geben das kannst du nochmal
kühlen lassen und alles verabschieden
für eine ganze weile
[Musik]
das ist der nächste morgen
aber das war noch lange nicht alles
insgesamt bleibt unser fleisch 17
stunden im ofen
[Musik]
es wird zeit
nach unserem video anzugucken
auf dieser fettfilm
[Musik]
es ist eine untertreibung zu sagen dass
das fleisch zerfällt
ich meine selbst
[Musik]
ihr fehlt an unsere brüder um eine
möglichst hohe reinheit zu bekommen
und dann ziehen wir das fleisch
[Musik]
um es noch saftiger zu machen geben wir
etwas von unserem konsumieren
[Musik]
und wir lassen es ruhen
das ist alles kein muss aber umso mehr
freut man sich darauf am ende zu essen
[Musik]
und jetzt wird es ernst freunde als
erstes werden wir unser fleisch gut auf
das fett ist ausgehärtet und lässt sich
so perfekt trennen
[Musik]
spätestens jetzt sollte dir verstehen
warum wir so fertiges fleisch benutzt
[Musik]
zeit für die tortillas
das ist mein erstes mal dass ich das
mache deshalb bin ich ja wissen
aufgeregt
[Musik]
aber das alles ist eigentlich wirklich
simpel gerade wenn man die richtigen
zutaten hat
[Musik]
vermengen durchkneten
und ruhen lassen
[Musik]
wenn die konsistenz wie knete ist hat
man alles richtig gemacht
[Musik]
mein erster portier
sieht doch gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
koriander
[Musik]
zwiebeln
limetten
pfizer werde habe ich zum ersten mal
miami gegessen und
die gehört einfach dazu
es ist soweit
[Musik]
unser höhe
dass wir unsere tortillas tippen
[Musik]
die heiße grillplatte
mozzarella
[Musik]
unser fleisch koriander und zwiebeln
und jetzt heißt es geduld haben und das
ganze knusprig auspacken
[Musik]
einer reicht natürlich nicht
diese geräusche
[Musik]
man weiß einfach dass das was kommt
wirklich lecker sein wird
und das ist die besonderheit bei borea
tacos
man gibt seine tage sind das konstrukt
und das ist einfach nicht von dieser
welt und
ganz wichtig
so etwas sollte man immer teilen
wir müssen
das ist einfach geil ist ein
schlachtfeld resümee cultra krank ultra
lecker und authentischer geschmack aber
die 50 stunden hätten auch sechs stunden
sein können weil das einfach so in der
natur der sache so ist so das bringt
nicht so her aber es hat sich trotzdem
sehr sehr genommen und der prozess droht
hat ihr müsst es nachmachen ist es so
danke fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten
mal